so talk to us polo man you're from
chinatown when you start doing this man
you're 22 now you said
yeah i just turned 22 in january how
long have you been doing this
like uh i first started rapping i could
remember i made my first route when i
was like nine
i uh went to the studio for the first
time when i turned 17.
i shot my first video at 18
and i got signed approaching three years
ago
how did you get discovered but i want to
know what [ __ ] is happening good for you
where's the hard times
i'm used to rabbits [ __ ] with hog and
get through
couldn't get signed now it kind of
happened fast though because oh [ __ ]
because it was really like me utilizing
youtube
to my advantage on uh social media like
i was on facebook heavy to
gain the fan base starting out do you
love the [ __ ] mother's face
book [ __ ] you've got me [ __ ] up yeah
you know you're here show your faith do
some crazy [ __ ] and a hundred million
people know you
yeah a little bit like that ain't that a
trip but i think i think in his
generation mike
like these guys are more uh it's just
it's a different attention
right it's a different gravitation to
the eye
is what they have been able to master at
a for their for their generation am i
right
yeah for sure tell me about your
brothers and sisters you have an older
sister
right yeah i got i got one older sister
she 24 and then i got a younger brother
he about 16. he'd be rapping too his
name
trendy he's in your crew though he got
his own crew
yeah you could say that we we gonna say
what's he saying that's my brother
sister do any rapping any kind of music
yeah my sister do music
too but she ain't really dropped the
first song again my my brother got music
on youtube helping this [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'll be um
pushing her to get in the studio she
just like her own biggest critic
you know but she's the one reason i do
music i used to look up to her
doing it and um i got a younger sister
too her name leia
she about eight years old oh [ __ ] little
baby yeah mm-hmm
since you got how many awards you ever
win that won the choice awards with the
kids and all that stuff
now as far as the wars go i know i never
want none
never been source awards and all that
stuff yeah no nothing that's coming your
way soon
for sure talk to me about the chain on
your neck man 13
130 this the block i'm from
from 1300 block up north on the north
side of chicago
everybody know that too huh yeah look
good
yeah because i've been watching i'm kind
of curious i don't know if you've seen
it
i think we talked about it mike you ever
seen you ever seen a tv show called the
the shy yeah that was fly i watched
like an episode or two before but i
never got into it i don't really watch
tv
the show is really fly i i think it'd be
good but i think it's i don't know you
know
obviously you're from chicago but this
takes place i think in particular the
south side
if he doesn't see where he's going he
just think he's going to be hip-hop but
you're going to be in movies and [ __ ]
no y'all want to act one day it's just
like right now i'm too shy for that
that's what you're going to do though
okay ain't you just gonna happen you'll
be acting rapping
acting like you're rapping
[Laughter]
you'll be the man